wenn du dir Ziele setzt kannst du alles
schaffen was für ein Bullshit guckt euch
nur mal unsere verkackte Energiewende an
bis 2030 soll insgesamt 80% des in
Deutschland produzierten Stroms aus
erneuerbaren Energien kommen dafür
müssten wir wie Olaf Scholz sich als
Ziel gesetzt hat fünf Windräder pro Tag
bauen momentan sind es 1,8 Hefte raus
matharbeit was ist mehr fünf oder ein ,8
doofe Frage aber die Ampel kann sie
nicht beantworten also müsst ihr das
auch nicht eigentlich wollten sie die
Planung beschleunigen und die
Genehmigungen
vereinfachen in Deutschland lassen wir
es doch einfach stehen wir zu unseren
Unfähigkeiten mein Ziel ist es nächstes
Jahr wieder in meine alte Badehose aus
den 70ern zu passen werde ich das
erreichen nein aber es ist mir
scheißegal